hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing youtube videos
because i want to share with you guys
all my experience and i want to show you
how we actually work as pro traders
so today i want to make another update
on amc guys because the stock is very
hard we saw some strong
moves yesterday not only on amc on all
the reddit stocks so i'm going to talk
about all of this
and show you guys what are my levels and
the reasons for me
for this strong moves to happen let's
get into it
[Music]
so very quickly let's have a look at the
chart first this is amc
on a daily time frame so for those who
have watched uh the video i did
yesterday
uh i was actually saying that 750 was
a resistance that i believe would
overcome
which happened in a very quick way
yesterday
so we're going to go through the news
very soon but first let's have a look at
the technicals guys because we are doing
technical analysis guys once again
all the news are already included in the
price action right
i mean markets are not really efficient
that's not what i mean
but all the information that we're gonna
find in the news can be read
in the chart guys so you don't actually
need
to see the news to trade the stock
that's what i mean
so uh here we were saying 750
is uh the resistance level for those who
want to know why just check my video i
did yesterday it's like
you know just a basic horizontal trend
line and let's see what happened during
this
session i was saying guys don't buy it
here
wait for a breakout and then wait for
re-test
and this is actually on the hourly
timeframe what we
see guys we see the breakout here we
have one two
three four five candles even on a four
hours time frame
on a four hours time frame it would be
harder to play
because i like to have two consecutive
candles above my
resistance to actually say that the
breakout is confirmed
here on the fourth time frame the second
candle is closing here so after the
second candle has closed
you don't have a re-test anymore so you
need
for this particular type of uh trade to
be on an
hourly time frame of course it's easy to
say after it happened i know
so you need to use both of them here the
one hour time frame was the right one to
use the two hours time frame would be
good as well but it's not
one that people actually use a lot one
two three four candles above the 750
level and then
we retested perfectly the 750
plus uh which one is it the 20 uh period
moving average so here guys you have a
double uh bullish signal
so buying here wouldn't be a good idea
you would have not feeling good here but
buying here with the stop loss here guys
this trade was gold
i mean you know safe easy to take and
you know i already gave you guys my view
on amc
i think that right now we overcame this
new resistance level
and i think that my scenario that i
described
in my yesterday's video is that we're
going to the 1.618
field extension ratio is 43.9 guys
we are heading there i don't know how
we're gonna go there
i'm not saying it's gonna be like three
uh you know
bullish days and we reach it probably
not because once again guys uh the short
interest has decreased dramatically in
amc
and you know this was a controversial
topic that i discussed yesterday in my
video
i was having you know some guys posting
on my uh videos like
you smoke bad stuff like this i try to
find them you know i go ninjin
i type the name and try to find them
they are not financial
people you know so they basically they
don't have information you know all the
stuff even for me it's not
very obvious all the time to understand
exactly the mechanisms behind
the data that is published which data
you can trust stuff like this
and i can tell you that those guys most
of them you really don't know what
they're talking about so don't listen to
them do your own research i showed you
guys how to do it
you take the daily volume for example if
you want to find out about amc short
interest
market b data is quite good so here you
have 37 million of
uh shares that is short and then the
total outstanding shares
public float ah you see market watch has
updated the data guys
just now okay they are the first one to
update it
cool okay i was about to show you guys
when uh is the data updated so right now
very interesting the data was supposed
to be released for those who want to
know
when the data is released i can i will
put this
link in the description of the
description of my video
and this thing is showing you guys all
the dates of
the reports that are going to be
released so for example the report of
the 12th of february
so it's every two weeks we had 29th of
jan
this the the new one is 12th of feb now
due date is
february 17th and supposed to be
released exchange
receipt date on the 24th of february so
actually yesterday guys so we have it
now i didn't have it like few hours ago
it just arrived
so now market watch has
good data because the public float is
375 million this is the correct data i
cross checked
this with many different sites uh
websites like bloomberg
marketbeat market watch and this is the
new number so this is correct it was
37 million now it's 48 million so the
total
short interest is 12 guys very
interesting
now we have it everybody gonna agree on
this finally
what does it mean it means guys that
this is a
normal situation this this stock is not
overshot
because as i showed you guys here
on market beat you go to institutional
ownership and you can see that so those
are hedge funds and asset managers you
can see that first quarter 2021 they're
buying
massively uh amc guys they are buying it
massively and of course they were
selling it massively in
2020 so you have redditors that are a
bullish
institutional clients now to you know to
buy the stock when it's at good levels
i'm not sure they're gonna buy it at
nine
or eleven right now even you can see
that aftermarket it's at
eleven guys so it takes 20 percent more
so this
what i'm looking here right now we are
here guys but just to conclude on the
show
interest so it's 12 percent i hope
everybody gonna agree this time on this
data that has
just been released right now and it
means guys that actually
those headphones if they see that the
value is too high
they're going to sell it